[Music]
and put yourself out there news
submitted by a game of loans a man's
video admitting he has no friends
resonates with people online yeah a lot
of people no friends online of course
yeah
so this man he is a recruitment firm CEO
he posted this video on LinkedIn he's a
loser he says he has no friends posting
on LinkedIn so one bar was saying I'm
not gonna make that connection bumpers
her LinkedIn was coming up oh I don't
know all the kids our kids are into it
now they're all the kids making fun of
it and then the kids are like nah
LinkedIn's tight oh my gosh [ __ ] isn't
it tight it's like the real like job
[ __ ] yeah but what's tight about it I
mean there's not a social place it's
like a pleasure to present yourself
professionally fart like work spam
emails for the rest of your life yeah
Bart I thought you said that guy was a
loser why are you talking like one man I
wish I had a Lincoln you can have a lake
they're free it's like you're online
succeed oh I don't know if you could be
a cool guy like us oh yeah what jobs you
were tuxedo to hormones big dreams okay
okay he wants to be a butler I think
that's the only profession where it's a
poor driver maybe a driver
why is tuxedo so low-cut so a little
class like that it's not low class it's
like only reserved for weddings and like
black-tie yeah so what job would you
wear it to unless you were like serving
a royal wedding or something sommelier
yeah exactly
Somali a a butler someone that is they
were to succeed us no really we just
wanted to throw the word out there do a
whopping throw to go
I'm [ __ ] up we just we just had a
connection I [ __ ] up I don't want it
take it back
Gio thanks for me Jesus big screen no I
don't speak for you I speak for me she's
my spokesperson No all right so I will
show you this video you can wear a
tuxedo be my spokesperson you should do
it I need someone to my spokesperson cuz
I'm gonna say [ __ ] that gets me in
trouble you know you can just wear it
succeed oh now you're the boss of your
own [ __ ] yeah we all know bosses wear it
succeed hello I am The Boss how do you
look these people just like this man you
should get you should make them wear
formal attire we've spotted cor my
wedding dress again oh yeah we should
have a wedding dress day look it's
pretty easy guys is why a beautiful
dress it's a good beat to you is
appropriate I would say the same thing
all right here's the video that mark
made and posted on LinkedIn and then it
went viral this is funny it's all
[ __ ] sad dude what the [ __ ] I have no
friends it's a scary thing to admit that
very specially he'll meet
I know a lot of people but it's mostly
through networking work if things do
with one I'm really lucky because I've
got some amazing work colleagues and
naturally we share our lives with each
other so we share what's going on but
you know I don't take math for dinner
and I don't unlock country works with
them I'm gonna do stuff with them to
friends day it's not just me as well
it's got my friends their eyes
staggering number of people and mostly
men across the UK we've got very few if
any people friends that they can
actually talk about any sort of serious
stuff with because you know you don't
want to be the sad lonely get the admit
having no friends but
sounds breguet longer and then it ends
up leading to him saying that he's gonna
be going to a pub to meet up with people
like a meet-up kind of thing mixer he
ended up going and then he vlogs
afterwards he was like that was amazing
like I met so many great people like I
can't call them friends yet but I
hopefully leads to that but he was just
so hopeful and he was pretty much saying
that he posted this to inspire other
people out there that are feeling lonely
to go out there and seek like literally
put yourself out there and seek social
clubs and like just the Internet can
allow you to do meetups in person and
there's really no excuse to be deloused
yeah I didn't know you could post videos
on LinkedIn that's why it's becoming hip
I think yeah it slaps the kids in here
with no friends you're the person you're
enough friends I'm excited about this
she's gonna go on LinkedIn now what the
way he's presenting it I relate to them
because I think like yeah a lot of dudes
hang out and stuff I got yourself a
loser yeah but I think like I think we
were fortunate enough maybe it started
with ask the field something like we
started to share our relationships with
each other in the group and we would
help help each other out in our
relationship but I think there are a lot
of dudes out there that can't or feel
uncomfortable talking about the
relationship so I think that's what he's
talking about it's like yeah bye dudes I
work with or go out with serious [ __ ]
yeah for me a friend is somebody who I
can call it any time they'll probably
pick up Yvonne or come help for
something yeah yeah I mean and that's
that to me is what a friend is so I get
what are you saying cuz you have work
colleagues and [ __ ] it's not the same
you can always I hit up on it Alan aim
your your online friends aim huh to be
relevant what happened you're not
slapping anymore yeah I'm talking about
when you don't have friends and you're
like the moderator or Eminem boy keeps
goin aim so he was a must laughing yeah
slap enough mark was saying that
recently he had bought two tickets to a
rugby match but like his his children
have already
left home his wife works away on the
weekends so he didn't have anyone to go
with and so he ended up watching this
match on TV instead so then that's what
kind of like made him realize like oh
[ __ ] I don't have any friends like you
know so then they're also reporting in
this article that this firm published a
study back in September saying that 28%
of people in Britain say that they don't
have a best friend
well 15 percent said that they have no
close friends and 8 percent said that
they don't have friends at all yeah so
then they were also saying that they
found that by living alone so like once
once you are discharged out of the
hospital that people have greater risk
of dying within a year when they live
alone or when they feel lonely for heart
problems and then they were also saying
that the journal heart found that living
alone was also associated with a 39
percent higher risk of cardiac events
like heart attack during a follow-up
period but this is among men only so 39
percent higher for men well because our
hearts are stronger they're just saying
that women have a larger social network
I think so I think so first rule
separation divorce death of a partner
may disadvantage men even more and so
they end up being the more lonelier
gender oh but [ __ ] man right can't leave
me I guess more present sure she'll bust
open her LinkedIn just so many fun oh
yeah I do think girls have a stronger
support network and most guys just by
nature we're more socially open yeah
we're more vulnerable with each other
whereas guys are more like internal and
like let's just shed whatever we're
feeling and not talk about it yeah we've
seen all each other's boobs I've seen
Casey's dick you see mine
whew stick that's really fun staple let
him need to see dicks to be friend are
you good one actually I'm right there
with you each other that's a good thing
you have a good friendship it does have
a weird friendship so if you don't see
my dick why would you call me Winnie no
no show you his dick right now covered
in [ __ ] Tabasco you swatted away his
bidding yeah yeah but there is something
about I don't know I don't know if it's
society or maybe it's the male biology
but there's something about dudes that
don't we don't just connect as much as
females do I don't know why and you guys
can I give you hobbies and [ __ ] yeah and
shared interest but that's that's what's
the part we're like we don't have that
strong of a social network emotional
intelligence yeah we don't have him as
much emotional intelligence a two dudes
or no fishing you know and after we're
done fishing we catch the fish or just
two dudes holding on to fish like cool
we're gonna cook it guys doing more than
that yeah
people because for me the way I approach
human interaction is with curiosity and
like genuine like wanting to learn from
a person and like getting to know this
person so I don't know like because I
think a lot of people do struggle with
connecting with people and like since my
brain doesn't work like that I wonder
like what is it that you think well so
ours is the same way it's curiosity but
we don't ask the right questions so I
glitzy if I'm getting to know Casey I'm
like oh cool so you're married is that
yeah all right cool
and then I'm like so like you know those
ribs you made like how did you make them
I think you just friends with more on
tomorrow but like a lot of dudes connect
like that and then after we're done
making the ribs it's like two dudes
looking at the ribs
all right because if one person says
something more vulnerable it'll they're
afraid of it looking weird to the other
person I don't know me it could be good
that's a guy thing for sure guys don't
want to seem sensitive at all he thinks
I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] or I'm being a
[ __ ] sometimes a guy is being a [ __ ]
and I do find it funny so it's it's a
duality that is definitely a thing
called overshare yeah all this
particular information judgment you know
girls have that judgment I'm pretty sure
they do but not in like the [ __ ] way
it's like um I guess more of like for me
if someone's to like materialistic like
right off the bat like I have like I
think each person has their different
things if someone's like very much like
all they talk about is like the price of
things are like how much they like what
what they bought or whatever I can't
connect and so for the longest time I
didn't have girlfriends because the
girls that were in that circle they
would only talk about like their purses
are how much things cost and I really
didn't understand it connect on that
level yeah so then I would judge people
right away off that like I noticed I was
doing that like if someone seemed kind
of cool but then immediately they
started talking about like I don't know
the price of clothes or something like
that I just would be like you're one of
those and then yeah or they could have
been a really cool person but I just
yeah I think that might be a similar
it's a first impression though it's not
your fault certain certain judgments off
different things yeah so as I think like
with your like back friends [ __ ] [ __ ]
move things where like if you judge a
guy for being a [ __ ] maybe if they
prove themselves in a different area
first and then they did a [ __ ] I have
plenty of guy friends who are also kind
of [ __ ] annoying right but other
qualities yeah I don't yeah you have to
you have to take the whole person in but
but if you're gonna be friends with
somebody you just seeing this [ __ ]
personally I don't want to deal with
this [ __ ] but if you but if you got a
friend who's like going through some
[ __ ] and like the bean composting it's
okay
I think but I guess guys are scared to
be [ __ ] with each other I think they
are but I think that it just depends on
what it is right cuz cuz yeah a lot of
guys are afraid tional weakness but I
don't think talking deeply about things
is weak like I don't know I don't think
so either and I think most guys if you
ask them one on one they all agree the
same way but then it still not happening
like we all open up to each other all
the time
which is really cool and then and and
it's funny too cuz me and Michael my
best friend we before we work on
anything like when we sit down and do
script it's just the same thing that we
all do like we kind of check in with
each other and like talk about [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] like I think especially as it as
a creative person when you are writing a
script or something you're kind of
opening up a side of yourself you know I
mean you're being creative and stuff and
so when you're able to do that with each
other first is like a baseline of like
I'm opening up with you know we're
talking about [ __ ] and checking in with
each other about what's going on lately
then you're able to just flow much
easier I find that we we flow much
better too once we once we get
everything we're thinking on the deck
then you're not sitting there storming
about whatever's in your head you know I
think we're also a little bit lucky
where it's part of the craft or writing
stories about people for sure versus
when we before that like if it's just a
slab of ribs I don't call life you know
he doesn't want ribs that's the problem
he wants to have deep conversations when
we're writing stories that it's part of
it you know so we're bonded so much yeah
but when it's just two guys like going
fishing it's like so is that how you
fish is that how you hook the fish cool
some people who's your friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]